>> PRESIDENT TRUMP IS STEAMED
WITH CHINA FOLLOWING A REPORT IT
WAS SECRETLY SELLING OIL TO
NORTH KOREA IN VIOLATION OF
UNITED NATIONS SANCTIONS.
A SOUTH KOREA PAPER PUBLISHED
U.S. SPY PHOTOS SHOWING CHINESE
PRESIDENT TRUMP TWEETED TODAY:
CAUGHT RED HANDED.
TONIGHT IN AN INTERVIEW WITH THE
"NEW YORK TIMES," THE PRESIDENT
SAID HE HAS BEEN SOFT ON CHINA
OVER TRADE IN HOPES THAT ITS
GOVERNMENT WILL PRESSURE NORTH
KOREA TO ABANDON ITS NUCLEAR
WEAPONS PROGRAM.
LET'S DISCUSS THIS WITH THE FOX
NEWS NATIONAL SECURITY ANALYST
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
YOU HAVE BEEN OUTSPOKEN ON A
NUMBER OF FOREIGN POLICY ISSUES.
ARI, LET ME START WITH YOU.
THE PRESIDENT HAD A GOOD YEAR ON
FOREIGN POLICY FOR A ROOKIE,
DON'T YOU THINK.
THE PRESIDENT HAS HAD A NUMBER
OF MAJOR FIASCOS.
FIRST LET ME SAY THIS.
OUR ALLIES ARE WORRIED ABOUT US
AND OUR ENEMIES --
>> WHICH ALLY IS WORRIED ABOUT
US?
>> GERMANY, THE UNITED KINGDOM.
THE PRESIDENT WOULD NOT SHAKE
HER HAND AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
WE HAVE A DEBATE WHETHER THE
PRESIDENT IS INVITED TO THE
ROYAL WEDDING FOR PRINCE HARRY.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING]
>> HOLD ON.
>> LET ME FINISH THE POINT.
JASON.
MY CONCERN IS AMERICA IS NO
LONGERED SEND UNDER DONALD
TRUMP.
-- LONGER ACCEPTED UNDER DONALD
>> I DISAGREE WITH.
LET'S TALK ABOUT CHINA AND NORTH
KOREA.
IT'S A DIFFICULT PROPOSITION.
WE HAVE FIVE SATELLITE PHOTOS
SHOWING THAT NORTH KOREA AND
NORTH KOREA?
>> WELL, WE HAVE THE DAILY
THEN YOU HAVE THE STRATEGIC
APPROACH.
THE NOVELTY OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IS THE EASTERN
ASIAN ALLIANCE IS BACK AND
RUNNING.
JAPAN AND OTHER PLAYERS.
THAT'S SENDING STRONG SIGNALS TO
CHINA AND THE DEPLOYMENT OF TASK
FORCES WHICH GENERATED A
UNANIMOUS VOTE.
ON THE OTHER HAND THE CHINESE
100 PRO-CHINESE OR SOUTH KOREA
SOUTH KOREA?
MORE DIPLOMAT WORK WITH CHINA.
ON THE GROUND IN THE EAST ASIAN
ALLIANCE, THERE IS CLEAR THERE
IS PRESSURE COMING FROM THAT
SIDE.
>> THERE WAS A STRONG VOTE IN
THE UNITED NATION.
NIKKI HALEY DID A GOOD JOB TO
AND THE SITUATION WE ARE IN
TODAY, WHAT DO YOU THINK THE
PRESIDENT SHOULD DO IN THIS
CASE?
>> JASON, IF YOU DON'T CUT ME UP
OR INTERRUPT ME FOR 30 SECONDS,
I PROMISE NOT TO WIPE THE FLOOR
WITH ANYBODY.
GIVE ME 30 SECONDS.
>> WE HAVE 10.
>> WE HAVE A UNANIMOUS VOTE IN
THE
TH
THE U.N. SECURITY COUNCIL.
LET TILLERSON DO HIS JOB.
THE PRESIDENT CAN'T WAKE UP
EVERY MORNING AND TWEET NONSENSE
AFTER PLANNING HIS GOLF GAME AND
VACATIONS AND IGNORE
INTELLIGENCE REPORTS.
THIS CURRENT SATELLITE PHOTOS
YOU?
ARE LOOKING AT THEM LIKE WE ARE
TODAY.
WHAT SHOULD THE PRESIDENT BE
DOING AT THIS POINT?
>> THE PRESIDENT FIRST AND
FOREMOST.
THE PRESIDENT SHOULD NOT HAVE
ENDEERED THE CHINESE SHARING
CAKE WITH THEM IN MAR A LAGO.
THE CHINESE HAVE MORE LEVERAGE
ON THE NORTH KOREA THAN ANYBODY
IN THE WORLD.
3rd, HE SHOULD IGNORE THE CALLS
FROM THE RUSSIAN FOREIGN
LEADERS.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS -- JASON.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> SORRY.
>> YOU ARE THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE.
>> YES.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING]
>> GOOD LUCK.
RUN IT.
>> DOCTOR, TELL ME WHAT YOU
THINK THE PRESIDENT SHOULD BE
DOING IN THIS CASE?
>> WELL, HE IS DOING IT.
HE CAN'T RELY ON ONE EVENING
NEWS REPORT ABOUT WHAT THE
CHINESE ARE DOING.
NORTH KOREA ARE LOOKING AT?
HIS TWEETS IN THE MORNING?
NO, THEY ARE LOOKING AT THE
MOVEMENT OF TASK FORCES AND THE
JOINT EXERCISES BETWEEN JAPAN
AND SOUTH KOREA AND THE GROWTH
OF THE INTERNATIONAL COALITIONS
THAT WANT TO ISOLATE NORTH
KOREA.
CHINA TODAY IS NOT THE CHINA OF
THE '50s.
THEY HAVE FINANCIAL INTERESTS
AROUND THE WORLD.
IT'S NOT JUST WHAT IS HAPPENING
BETWEEN CHINA AND THE UNITED
STATES BUT INTERNATIONALLY.
>> THEY PLAY TRUMP FOR A FOOL.
>> OVERLY OVERWEIGHT --